allora voglio partire con una domanda vi
chiedo di rispondere di pancia
se vi chiedo come va al mondo oggi bene
o male per alzata di mano chi pensa che
vada bene ok
abbassate le mani chi pensa che il mondo
vada male
ok fate fate un po i conti voi allora
questo grafico l'ha fatto hans rosling
un geniale scienziato svedese forse
l'avete già visto e ci fa vedere cosa è
successo negli ultimi 200 18 anni nel
1800 ciascuno di questi pallini
rappresenta un paese della terra e
vedete in verticale l'aspettativa di
vita in orizzontale vedete il reddito il
puntino più avanzato giallo piccolissimo
e l'inghilterra nel 1800 aspettativa di
vita 40 anni il reddito medio
equivalente a quello di oggi 2.500 euro
guardate cosa è successo negli ultimi
200 anni
ecco vedete durante l'ottocento non
succede quasi niente
il reddito un po aumenta però
l'aspettativa di vita è sempre
bassissima guardate cosa succede al
volgere del secolo
vedete il buco nella prima guerra
mondiale il ripreso subito vedete la
seconda guerra mondiale
adesso guardate cosa succede al
dopoguerra in poi questa accelerazione
questa spinta straordinaria vedete
proprio una trasformazione nella nostra
società tutta la popolazione tutti i
paesi della terra che raggiungono un
livello di benessere di aspettative di
vita assolutamente straordinari ecco c'è
una spinta un motore straordinario che
ha reso possibile questa è la tecnologia
e c'è un ramo il braccio operativo della
tecnologia il business attraverso le
aziende le attività imprenditoriali noi
siamo riusciti a trasformare la
condizione umana in una maniera
straordinaria e quindi oggi ci sono
tutta una serie di indicatori che vedete
qui da povertà educazione
alfabetizzazione democrazia vaccinazione
mortalità infantile tutti questi indici
sono straordinariamente positivi come
non avremmo mai immaginato qualche
decennio fa
allo stesso tempo però vi chiedo di
proiettarvi un po nel futuro e allora vi
faccio un'altra domanda quando pensiamo
al futuro ci sembra distante chiedo
quanti di voi in questa sala avete figli
per alzata di mano che una buona metà
provate a pensare in che anno avranno la
vostra età di oggi oppure se non avete
figli i bambini che nascono nel 2018 in
che anno avranno la vostra età di oggi
ecco nel mio caso arrivò il 2051 e 2055
quindi pensate non è successo nei
precedenti 200 anni immaginate con
questa accelerazione straordinaria cosa
può succedere nei prossimi 20 30 40 anni
pensando che noi stiamo vivendo delle
dinamiche che non sono lineari ma sono
esponenziali quindi esponenziale vuol
dire che per un sacco di tempo non
succede nulla e poi una specie di
esplosione e vedete quando sono nato io
c'erano meno di 4 miliardi di persone
sulla terra adesso ce ne sono quasi 8
mila
hardy vi rendete conto che viviamo
un'epoca di disruption di accelerazione
inimmaginabile di tutta una serie di
aspetti tutta una serie di trend sia
positivi che negativi infatti la stessa
dinamica la troviamo praticamente
ovunque ci sono centinaia di parametri
di indicatori di attività e gli tv
impatti che seguono lo stesso tipo di
andamento quindi per un sacco di tempo
sembra non succede niente poi ho questa
esplosione noi siamo nel mezzo di questa
esplosione
nello stesso tempo viviamo su un pianeta
che è sempre lo stesso da miliardi di
anni
una volta c'erano tanto pianeta poche
persone adesso ci sono tantissime
persone il pianeta è sempre quello
ne abbiamo adottato un modello economico
che poi ha delle conseguenze che ci ha
portato al successo fino ad oggi ma non
è lo stesso modello che ci traghetterà
verso un futuro che si è desiderabile e
quindi vi faccio vedere cosa sta
succedendo oggi nel mezzo del pacifico
nell'atollo delle midway mi guardate
queste immagini
[Musica]
ecco questo è quello che succede quando
noi adottiamo un modello di business che
funziona fino a un certo punto ma non è
lo stesso che ci può portare nel futuro
noi vediamo cosa sta succedendo agli
animali a gli albatros delle midway ma
in realtà la stessa cosa sta succedendo
a noi come esseri umani quindi se noi
guardiamo quest'immagine pensiamo
all'allattamento oggi ci sono in alcune
zone del pianeta quelle più inquinate ci
sono centinaia migliaia di sostanze
chimiche tossiche che sono riscontrati
nel latte materno il latte materno
dovrebbe essere trattato come un rifiuto
tossico
questo senza andare tanto in là anche
nelle zone più inquinate dell'italia per
non parlare poi della cina o altre
regioni del pianeta
e chiaro che dobbiamo completamente
trasformare il nostro modello economico
dobbiamo trasformare i nostri paradigmi
e l'altra riflessione voglio fare con
voi e questa vedete questa linea rossa
800 metri parco sempione proprio qua due
passi se noi consideriamo un corpo umano
come volume sono circa 70 litri tutta
l'umanità tutta la specie umana può
essere contenuta dentro un cubo di 800 x
800 x 800 metri il volume di tutti gli
esseri umani oggi sulla terra
nello stesso tempo questo puntino
microscopico questo pixel rispetto alle
dimensioni del pianeta usando la
tecnologia e usando i nostri modelli di
business riesce a impattare il
funzionamento dell'intero pianeta e vi
rendete conto che la velocità non è
lineare il futuro non sarà una
proiezione di quello che abbiamo vissuto
nel passato nel futuro vedremo
un'accelerazione drastica di tutta una
serie di fenomeni e vedete questa ruota
rappresenta tutti i paesi della terra e
queste barche che si muovono sono le
temperature misurate medie rispetto allo
0 storico e guardate cosa succede dal
2000 in poi ovviamente più diventa rosso
più il pianeta si sta scaldando e vedete
la non linearità di questi cambiamenti
vedete senso d'urgenza che ci porta a
cambiare
quello che è successo praticamente dal
2000 in poi che gli oceani hanno
esaurito la loro capacità di assorbire
il calore l'emissione in eccesso e
quindi la terra invece di continuare
assorbire i nostri impatti comincia a
diventare una emettitrice comincia a non
essere più in grado di reggere il nostro
impatto
quindi dobbiamo passare da un modello
che estrattivo non intendo legato
all'industria mineraria intendo un
modello di business che è guidato da un
unico obiettivo guardare dove sia il
valore raccoglierlo e concentrarlo
estrarlo e concentrarlo estrarlo e
concentrarlo perché questa macchina
straordinaria che al business che
l'azienda oggi se guardiamo il modello
dominante guidata da un unico obiettivo
distribuire dividendi agli azionisti un
massimizzare valore per gli azionisti
quindi se c'è questo unico obiettivo
vuol dire una cosa molto semplice ma
quasi scioccante le persone e il pianeta
non rientrano negli obiettivi di
business
vi rendete conto che se ha funzionato
fino ad oggi nella condizione e con la
velocità di cambiamento che stiamo
vivendo non potrà funzionare il futuro è
fondamentale cambiare e per dare un'idea
di quanto bene funzioni questo modello
vi faccio vedere questa equazione sempre
un po strana 8 uguale 4 miliardi
questo modello di concentrazioni valore
funziona talmente bene che oggi 8 esseri
umani sulla terra tanti quanti possono
stare su questo carrello da golf hanno
la stessa ricchezza dei 4 miliardi di
persone più povere sul pianeta
quindi il business è una forza
straordinaria è come lo sono i terremoti
come lo sono i vulcani come lo sono gli
eventi climatici però è giunto il
momento di trasformarlo nella sua
essenza è giunto il momento di
trasformarlo in qualcosa che invece di
essere estrattivo e rigenerativo
qualcosa che riconosce l'interdipendenza
con tutte le con tutti gli attori con
tutto il sistema di cui è parte
vi faccio leggere questa frase ogni
azienda deve servire uno scopo sociale
deve produrre
risultati non solo finanziari ma anche
beneficiare tutti i portatori di
interesse azionisti dipendenti clienti e
comunità in cui operano
ecco quando l'ho visto la prima volta ho
pensato che l'avesse scritta non so
adriano olivetti qualche imprenditore
veramente così mitologico quasi in
realtà questo è un estratto della
lettera che è stata mandata all'inizio
di quest'anno da larry fink che è
l'amministratore delgato del più grande
fondo di investimento al mondo a tutti
gli amministratori delegati delle
aziende in cui fondo investe nel riff
indice a tutte le aziende in cui il
fondo investe blackrock gestisce quasi 7
trilioni di patrimonio circa tre volte
più di tre volte il pil dell'italia dice
qual è la vostra vocazione dovete
mettere la vocazione dovete avere un
significato dovete avere un ruolo per
impattare positivamente il pianeta è
quello che lui dice se voi non
considerate questa vocazione avrete dei
ritorni sarete meno profit ball andrete
peggio delle altre aziende perché non
siete adatti alle sfide che dobbiamo
affrontare collettivamente
ecco in questo contesto nascono le
benefi corporation e benefit corporation
rappresentano l'evoluzione forse la
rappresentazione più spinta di quello
che è un business sostenibile nel
concetto di usare il business come forza
positiva come possiamo usare questa
straordinaria potenzialità per
contribuire a risolvere le grandi sfide
del nostro tempo
quindi qualsiasi azienda può cominciare
il re interpreta se reinventarsi in
questa direzione e quindi può cominciare
a diventare rigenerativa vuol dire che
questa azienda misura quello che conta e
gestisce tutti i suoi impatti con la
stessa completezza con lo stesso rigore
che oggi viene riservato alle
misurazioni di tipo economico
finanziario un'azienda rigenerativa ha
una vocazione che viene scritta nello
statuto negli stati uniti esiste una
forma giuridica già dal 2010 che
riconosce queste aziende che non sono
for profit sono oltre il profit sono for
benefit ne hanno la vocazione
scritta l'oggetto sociale un'azienda
rigenerativa compete non per essere la
migliore al mondo ma per essere la
migliore per il mondo e quindi se noi
immaginiamo che tutte le aziende o
sempre più aziende vanno in questa
direzione
la conseguenza che usiamo il business
per creare una prosperità durevole una
prosperità condivisa
il pensiero di kennedy che si avvera e
quindi qui ispirandomi a carlo maria
cipolla ho provato a rappresentare in
questo grafico quali sono le principali
tipologie di aziende o di organizzazioni
ci sono diciamo i buoni che creano un
impatto positivo verso gli altri e non
necessariamente creano un valore per gli
azionisti
poi ci sono le locuste quelle che
distruggono sia valore per gli altri si
e valore per se stessi qui cipolla in
realtà direbbe sono gli stupidi che
fanno un danno agli altri fanno un danno
anche se stessi
poi la grande maggioranza delle aziende
sono queste estrattive che generano un
valore per se stesse genera un valore
per gli azionisti non necessariamente
generano un valore per tutti gli altri
e infine ci sono le aziende rigenerative
e quindi le benefit corporation creano
un valore tanto per se stessi quanto per
gli altri e quindi questo se vogliamo è
un modello già disponibile oggi che ci
auspichiamo si diffonda il più possibile
bob schiller nobel per l'economia nel
2013 qualche anno fa disse credo che le
benefit corporation saranno più
profittevoli degli altri tipi di aziende
proprio perché rispondono alle esigenze
del nostro secolo
e queste sono aziende che usano la
tecnologia per fare una cosa che in
passato non è mai stata possibile
misurare tutti i propri impatti misurare
quello che conta in maniera completa e
rigorosa e quindi da una dozzina d'anni
fa è stata creata questa piattaforma
tecnologica si chiama b impact
assessment disponibile accessibile a
chiunque nel mondo che consente di
capire se un azienda sta creando o
distruggendo valore per la società
quindi non solo valore economico ma
anche valore ambientale valore sociale
quindi oggi è possibile per un'azienda
prendere tutti i propri dati misurare
tutte le proprie attività e usando la
tecnologia fare una cosa che qualche
anno fa non era possibile capire se
rispetto a questa scala da 0 a 200 punti
ci troviamo sotto o sopra questa soglia
diciamo di equilibrio di eccellenza di
80 punti sotto gli 80 punti vuol dire
che un azienda estrattiva che prende dal
mondo più valore di quanto crei sopra
gli 80 punti vuol dire che rigenerativa
crea più valore di quanto ne prenda e
quindi ci auspichiamo che ce ne siano il
più possibile ed oggi abbastanza
difficile superare questa soglia
quindi vedete questo è un grafico
rappresenta nel mondo ci sono più di 70
mila aziende che si sono misurate con
questo protocollo e sono solo 2650 che
superano questa soglia però dimostra una
cosa fondamentale che è possibile
queste sono tutte aziende che hanno
misurato i loro impatti e in 60 paesi
140 industrie diverse ci dimostrano che
è possibile condurre quasi qualsiasi
business in modo tale da creare più
valore sociale ambientale economico di
quanto se ne prenda vi rendete conto di
quanto sia rivoluzionario questo
concetto
allora nel 2012 cosa abbiamo fatto
quando abbiamo fondato nativa abbiamo
preso questo modello dagli stati uniti
abbiamo detto se esiste la lo possiamo
fare anche da noi abbiamo chiamato
avvocati abbiamo chiamato nota i
giuristi ci siamo messi abbiamo scritto
uno statuto in cui scrivevamo che lo
scopo di nativa era di essere un'azienda
rigeneratrice andare oltre questo
concetto di profit quindi fatta
l'azienda andiamo alla camera di
commercio che cosa succede il nostro
statuto viene respinto come viene
respinto vi proponiamo una cosa bella
innovativa straordinaria già c'è non
chiediamo niente nessuna no no no non si
può fare perché la legge proibisce che
una società di capitali faccia qualcosa
di diverso da produrre valore per gli
azionisti
quindi questa cosa non si può fare noi
insistiamo viene respinto una seconda
volta viene respinto una terza viene
respinta una quarta la quinta volta per
sfinimento l'impiegato
della camera di commercio dice va bene
va bene dai lo registriamo non se ne
accorgerà nessuno e quindi cominciamo a
operare in questo libro in questa area
grigia speriamo che non se ne accorga
nessuno e andiamo avanti con le nostre
attività
questo però diciamo non ci va giù
allora con paolo di cesare co fondatore
di nativa cominciamo ad attivarci
cominciamo a contattare delle persone
che possono capire l'opportunità possono
aiutarci introdurre questa innovazione
creiamo un gruppo di lavoro che nel giro
di 14 mesi praticamente scrive un
disegno di legge
questo disegno di legge viene presentato
al senato viene recepito come
emendamento della legge di stabilità del
2016 equa vedete 22 dicembre 2015 la
legge passa questo sono io col senatore
delbarba paolo di cesare e per la prima
volta viene introdotto in italia una
nuova forma giuridica di impresa che
riconosce le società benefit che sono
aziende che nell'esercizio delle loro
attività economiche oltre lo scopo di
dividere gli utili perseguono uno più
finalità di beneficio comune è una
riscrittura del dna delle aziende per
cui l'italia diventa il primo stato
sovrano al mondo ad avere questa forma
giuridica
oggi esiste in 34 stati negli stati
uniti in italia in colombia e ci sono
altri 15 paesi della terra che stanno
introducendo lo stesso modello e quindi
l'italia si ritrova ad essere il paese
al mondo in cui questo modello sta
crescendo più rapidamente
abbiamo più di 85 aziende che superano
questa soglia di 80 punti misurata
verificata e certificata e abbiamo più
di 300 aziende che hanno adottato questa
forma giuridica
complessivamente in europa quando è nata
nativa eravamo il paziente zero non
c'era nessuna benefit corporation oggi
tra benefit corporation e di core
certificati ce ne sono più di 700 quindi
l'italia oggi si ritrova a essere un
laboratorio planetario da tutto il mondo
ci guardano e dicono com'è possibile
vogliamo che questo modello questo che
state facendo in italia
si diffonda anche in altri paesi quindi
crediamo che questo concetto di azienda
rigeneratrice se anche molto vicino al
nostro dna sia molto vicino al nostro
tessuto imprenditoriale e quindi io mi
auguro che se voi siete cittadini e
cominciate a guardare quello che
comprate da dove viene chi l'ha fatta un
impatto positivo o negativo se siete
imprenditori la vostra azienda sta
creando distruggendo valore lo sapete
l'avete mai misurato oggi c'è modo di
farlo se siete amministratori ci sono
decine di città nel mondo oggi questo è
un esempio della città di new york che
stanno adottando questo modello e lo
stanno diffondendo perché ovviamente più
aziende di questo tipo ci sono in un
dato territorio meglio è dal punto di
vista economico dal punto di vista
sociale dal punto di vista ambientale
io sono diciamo positivo ottimista
nonostante quello che ho fatto vedere
all'inizio perché credo che i popoli e
nazioni si comportino saggiamente però
dopo aver esaurito le altre opportunità
quindi io non so se abbiamo esaurito
proprio tutte le opportunità credo che
questo muro si sta avvicinando molto più
rapidamente di quanto comunemente si
pensi ma credo anche che abbiamo tutte
le possibilità tutti gli strumenti che
ci manca forse solo un piccolo salto di
volontà per accelerare questa
trasformazione positiva grazie
[Musica]